Traduttore: Giusy Morza
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Beh, questo mondo digitale,
questa trasformazione digitale
dentro la quale siamo immersi,
ogni giorno ci stimola nuove domande.
Ma forse ce n'è una
che più frequentemente
ci viene in mente ed è:
"Mi posso fidare?"
Mi posso fidare che riceveremo le scarpe
che abbiamo ordinato su internet?
Mi posso fidare
di questo nuovo ristorante?
Mi posso fidare di quel driver Uber
invece del tassista che abbiamo incontrato
fuori dalla stazione e ci ha fermato lì?
Possiamo fidarci di trovare veramente
quella casa che abbiamo ordinato
e prenotato su internet?
Bene, le blockchain ci aiutano
proprio a gestire meglio questa fiducia.
Questa fiducia nel mondo digitale.
Ma come fanno?
Beh, pensiamo a tanti computer.
Tanti computer collegati in rete,
come dei nodi di questa rete
e questi nodi che cosa fanno:
controllano la validità
di queste transazioni.
Ma transazioni diverse,
possono essere lo scambio di denaro,
possono essere lo scambio di pratiche
tra enti pubblici,
possono essere la sottoscrizione
di polizze digitali,
possono essere lo scambio
delle cartelle cliniche tra ospedali,
ma lo scambio
di qualsiasi altro bene digitale.
In effetti, le blockchain
proprio distribuiscono
ai nodi della rete la responsabilità
di fare il controllo sulla validità
e sulla consistenza di queste transazioni.
E quando questi nodi trovano un consenso
sulla validità di queste transazioni
le mettono in dei registri digitali
e strutturano dei blocchi di transazioni
concatendandoli l'uno all'altro.
E queste sono le blockchain.
Beh le blockchain
hanno tantissime tecnologie.
Ma di fatto è proprio questa
validazione condivisa
che è la tecnologia alla base
di questa nuova fiducia digitale
e che magari ci aiuterà a rispondere
in parte alla nostra domanda iniziale.
Immaginiamo adesso questa rete di nodi
e di registri come un notaio,
ad esempio sarà capitato a molti
di dover comprare o vendere una casa
e quando dobbiamo fare
l'atto di compravendita
abbiamo bisogno di un notaio, giusto?
Proprio per non prendere delle fregature
e tra le altre cose questo notaio cosa fa?
Per esempio, verifica
l'identità delle parti,
verifica che queste parti abbiano
in effetti la proprietà o l'utilizzo
o abbiano la possibilità fondamentalmente
di potersi scambiare la casa
e i soldi da una parte e dall'altra.
Certificheranno la data,
ma soprattuttto verificheranno
che la transazione avvenga
in modo consistente,
cioè che avvenga il trasferimento
di possesso della casa
e il trasferimento di denaro.
Beh, pensiamo alle blockchain
come a un notaio digitale distribuito
che permette a persone, ad aziende,
a processi, a computer,
che sono indipendenti l'uno dall'altro,
che potenzialmente non si conoscono
e che non necessariamente
si fidano l'uno dell'altro,
di poter fare delle transazioni sicure,
di potersi scambiare dei beni digitali,
ma soprattutto di poterlo fare
senza che ci sia una entità centrale.
Un'entità centrale che
controlla queste transazioni
che le certifica di fatto, senza
le cosiddette ''terze parti fidate''.
Ed è proprio così
che nascono le blockchain.
Nascono proprio dalla necessità
di eliminare gli intermediari,
in quelle transazioni online
che tutti noi facciamo
nel mondo dell'e-commerce.
Ma soprattutto per ridurre
i costi di transazione.
In effetti le parole 'bitcoin'',
criptovalute sicuramente le conosciamo
meglio, ci sono più note,
ma di fatto tutte hanno
la tecnologia blockchain dietro
e proprio questi
registri digitali distribuiti.
E tutti di fatto hanno l'obiettivo
di creare sistemi
di transazione sicuri, indipendenti
basati su questa validazione condivisa
ma soprattuto per ridurre
il costo delle transazioni.
Beh, ma allora
cosa c'entrano le blockchain
con questa trasformazione digitale?
La trasformazione digitale,
se ci pensiamo un attimo, ci fa muovere
su una sottile linea,
una sottile linea di confine
tra velocità e fiducia.
E pensiamo a quella funzionalità
del "One-click checkout"
che molti di voi usano su Amazon
che semplicemente con il tocco di un dito
facciamo ordine e pagamento.
Molti di voi l'avranno usata e di fatto
questo ci risparmia molti dei controlli.
Ci richiede molta fiducia,
se non altro in noi stessi.
Ma d'altra parte, dalla nostra
esperienza d'acquisto
una grande velocità,
una semplicità diventa
molto più piacevole.
Bene, le blockchain
muovono in modo radicale
questa linea di confine
tra velocità e fiducia
e la fanno proprio
in quei sistemi distribuiti
che sono alla base
della trasformazione digitale
e li rendono più efficienti
e più sicuri.
E questo lo stanno facendo
sia nel mondo della tecnologia
sia nel mondo dell'economia,
ma forse soprattutto
nel mondo dei social media.
Bene, nel mondo delle tecnologie
pensiamo a quei sistemi basati
sui microservizi o sui big data.
Beh, in questi ambiti non necessariamente
ci sono delle entità centrali
che coordinano il tutto
e forse non dovrebbero
neanche esistere queste entità centrali.
E proprio in questi ambiti
le blockchain avranno
un ruolo fondamentale
per aiutarci a tracciare i dati
in modo completo.
Per esempio, aiutarci a mantenere
la consistenza dei dati
in una situazione in cui i dati
sono replicati volontariamente
oppure a darci trasparenza
in queste reti complesse di servizi.
O darci affidabilità
rispetto a quelle fonti dati esterne
che ormai utilizziamo quasi sempre
per prendere delle decisioni.
E nel mondo economico?
Nel mondo economico, se è vero che
la missione delle blockchain
è quella di ridurre
il costo delle transazioni,
allora vuol dire
che stanno ponendo le basi,
lo stanno facendo veramente,
di nuove catene del valore.
Più dinamiche, ad assetto variabile
Catene del valore
che non avevamo pensato prima.
Pensate a quello che succede
nel mondo delle assicurazioni.
Adesso compagnie assicurative,
broker, possono offrire,
possono negoziare,
quelli che sono i grandi rischi
dei loro clienti.
Possono sottoscrivere polizze
e possono gestirle su tutta la loro vita,
grazie agli "smart contract."
E gli "smart contract" sono
proprio un altro pezzo fondamentale
nella nostra storia delle blockchain.
Perchè gli "smart contract" ci aiutano
a scrivere quelle che sono
le regole dei contratti,
quelle che sono
le condizioni dei contratti.
E soprattutto ci permettono
di rendere immediatamente eseguibili
quelle condizioni contrattuali
quando si verificano proprio quelle
che sono le precondizioni
a queste regole.
Quindi rendono veramente
molto veloce ed efficiente la gestione
di tutto il ciclo di vita dei contratti
e riducono in modo drastico
le transazioni.
Ma forse è proprio nel mondo
dei sistemi sociali distribuiti
dove le blockchain
ci potranno dare più una mano,
dove forse potrà essere
maggiore il loro contributo.
Forse più auspicabile, proprio
per sviluppare questa fiducia reciproca.
Pensiamo un attimo
a quei fattori che hanno messo in crisi
negli ultimi mesi
la nostra fiducia nei social media
e quali sono stati?
Le fake news, le false identità,
i trolls, la mercificazione
dei nostri dati personali
Le fake news sono un fenomeno
con cui ci dovremo confrontare molto
nei prossimi anni
e d'altra parte, i sistemi che abbiamo
attualmente sulla rete
non ci aiutano molto
perché sono basati
sulla raccomandazione, sull'interesse,
è basata sui like,
sulla condivisione dei link
su sistemi di "upvote."
sistemi che fondamentalmente
sono stati del tutto inadeguati.
Le fake news ci hanno dimostrato
che sono facilmente aggirabili
da persone malintenzionate
da robot, da entità dedite
esclusivamente a diffondere
delle bufale sulla rete.
Proprio con l'obiettivo
di orientare l'opinione pubblica,
sfruttando quella grande potenza
di fuoco dei social media.
Beh, per fortuna ci sono
alcune nuove società,
alcune start up
che stanno cercando di utilizzare
le blockchain
per combattere le fake news,
alcune di queste anche italiane.
Ce n'è una molto interessante:
il suo concept è molto interessante
USER FEEDS
che utilizzando dei metodi di Ethereum
fondamentalmente crea dei protocolli
e delle comunità di validatori di notizia,
dei validatori di contenuti
che sono remunerati.
Sono remunerati in base
al lavoro di verifica
delle fonti che fanno.
E quindi sono incentivati a evitare
che queste bufale si diffondano
sui social media.
L'altro tema fondamentale
nella nostra società digitale
è la protezione dei nostri dati personali.
Da una parte sicuramente
la nuova normativa europea,
probabilmente qualcuno
ne ha sentito parlare,
la GDPR, sta aumentando la coscienza
e sta accelerando
quello che stanno
facendo le aziende
per proteggere i nostri dati.
Ma d'altra parte,
dal nostro punto di vista
l'utilizzo delle blockchain
ci può aiutare ad avere
i nostri registri digitali
delle nostre informazioni personali
e di definire ed eseguire regole
per controllare il loro utilizzo,
la loro diffusione e perchè no,
la loro remunerazione.
Anche in questo ambito
ci sono alcune start up interessanti
proprio che lavorano con le blockchain
per proteggere le identità digitali,
proprio per farci riappropriare
dei nostri dati personali.
Il concept di una di queste,
che si chiama ELIX
è particolarmente interessante,
perchè partendo dal concetto che
le identità digitali sono il DNA
di internet, allora facilita il governo
delle nostre informazioni personali
attraverso delle sottoidentità,
come degli avatar.
Che gestiscono tutte
e sole le informazioni,
tutte e sole le regole per gestire
particolari sistemi specifici:
sistemi di autenticazione.
Per esempio, i nostri dati personali
per i nostri account email,
o per la nostra smart tv
o per la nostra smart card.
Ma alla fine, quello che sappiamo
forse l'abbiamo sempre saputo.
Che la fiducia reciproca è di fatto
alla base delle nostre relazioni sociali.
Sia nel mondo reale
sia nel mondo digitale.
E come i social network hanno
creato l'infrastruttura
per creare queste relazioni sulla rete,
le blockchain e la loro evoluzione
potranno creare l'infrastruttura
per sviluppare la fiducia
in queste relazioni.
Grazie.
[Applausi]